Loen lucky directed by Steven Soderbergh
stars Channing Tatum Adam driver and
Daniel Craig it's about a heist an ass
collar heist NASCAR in America so where
I'm not gonna do the whole review like
that even though I'm tempted this film
as I said is directed by Steven
Soderbergh he's returning from a 4-year
supposed retirement after behind the
candelabra he said you know what I'm not
gonna make movies anymore
and he stuck with TV for a while but now
he's back making a feature film which is
something I'm pretty excited about
because I've always really appreciated
his way of directing movies he makes
films that sometimes feel like they
could be a big studio movie based off of
their plot but he approaches them from
an auteur perspective he makes art films
the most mainstream he's ever gotten was
the first Ocean's eleven film and it is
one of his best films but he never let
his arthouse roots detract from the fact
that he was making a conventional heist
movie and his return to feature
filmmaking here I think is really
welcomed but this movie isn't going to
blow anyone away I think it's a really
well directed film with gorgeous
cinematography as usual his
cinematographer is Peter Andrews who's
actually him and this one was written by
Rebecca blunt who I think might be him
as well because she has no credits I
have no proof of this but it's
definitely a pseudonym for sure this
film is a fun watch but its biggest flaw
for me was that it never emotionally
invested me in the heist there's no
reason to feel motivated for them
pulling off this heist
there's no Andy Garcia who's screwing
George Clooney's wife there's nothing to
get angry about Channing Tatum does lose
his job and you recognize that some of
these people really need money but
beyond that you don't really care that
much on whether or not they get away
with it or not but what saved this film
for me was the immaculate cinematography
Soderbergh again has delivered a
beautiful looking movie Daniel Craig as
Jo bang who is one of the best
characters in the movie and a real scene
stealer and Adam driver who plays one of
the brothers trying to pull this heist
off who's an Iraq war vet who lost his
arm even though he constantly tells
everyone that was just his hand and
forearm which is like a big thing in
this movie for him the charisma from all
the actors involved and the breezy look
and
we love the movie really made it
enjoyable wash it is however not this
mind-blowing hilarious comic masterpiece
that some people are referring to it as
that's just my opinion of course but I
think Ocean's eleven is far better and
those comparisons are bound to happen I
mean even a character in this film
refers to the heist they're trying to
pull off as ocean 7/11 so he knows it's
very tongue-in-cheek he's not trying to
make some big pretentious movie while
some who see this film might think that
this is Steven Soderbergh's most
mainstream film and quite some time and
I think a lot of people will enjoy it
but some will go to it expecting more of
a non-stop romp of hilarity and that's
not what this film is what I think is
actually most commendable about this
film has nothing really to do about the
movie itself but the way in which
they've chosen to distribute it one of
the biggest reasons Soderbergh walked
away from directing was because he felt
that Hollywood was taking the power away
from filmmakers so with his return he
has chosen to completely independently
distribute this movie this isn't being
put in theaters by some big company he's
making a huge gamble they kind of formed
their own company and they're trying to
distribute it to theaters and hopefully
people will go to see it which could
start a trend of filmmakers getting a
little more power in Hollywood to make
the films they want to watch which i
think is really awesome all that being
said sometimes Soderbergh chooses to
focus on smaller scenes or moments that
are imperative for the heist to work but
they feel like they just make the pacing
drag a child beauty-pageant
or someone's inability to drive stick or
an automatic car and these things need
to be in the script for certain things
to eventually come through flashback
form later and you're like clicking off
things in your head oh I see why they
had that in there but when you're
watching the movie it can get a little
boring sometimes to be honest Soderbergh
has always had a hard time connecting
with general audiences versus those who
want to go see a film because a lot of
people want to go to see a movie and
they just want to see a movie they want
to be entertained and then others they
want to go to see a film they want to
see something that's artful that can
have an impact on them beyond just two
hours of entertainment and some good
tasting popcorn Soderbergh makes movies
that have conventional movie plots but
the way he directs them are so much more
artful than others and sometimes that
can clash with its audience so I'm
curious to see how audiences react to
Logan lucky because critics seems
be really liking it I enjoyed the film
it's not a mind-blowing masterpiece as
some critics have referred to it as and
I do not think it's better than Ocean's
eleven but it's a fun movie with good
performances and great cinematography
I'm gonna give Logan lucky Abby - guys
thank you very much as always for
watching look forward to more Stephen
King reviews this weekend I have some
cool stuff planned we've been working
really hard on some fun shorts that
we're going to include in those skits
and I got to film at the Ohio State
Reformatory where they shot Shawshank
Redemption that place is haunted as hell
I'm serious like weird things happened
while we were there we heard strange
noises lights went on and off I even
caught something on film but all
including the video that could have been
a complete coincidence but the timing
was amazing and I can't wait to share
that with you guys in the next few weeks
or so it's still in editing thank you
very much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you